hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll and
today we're going to get a special solo
edition of mindscape which we
occasionally do when we have a new book
coming out at the same time as we have
the podcast ongoing so i think this is
the second time that this has happened
we did this before for something deeply
hidden my book about quantum mechanics
the new book which arrives on september
20th 2022 is the biggest ideas in the
universe volume 1 space time and motion
the book is of course based on the video
series the youtube videos that i did at
the beginning of the pandemic in 2020
and it's a little bit of a departure
both for me and for the world of physics
books out there for me because
usually in my trade book writing i'm
trying to make an argument about
something that may or may not be true
trying to convince people that there is
a good way of thinking about something
whether it's the arrow of time or
naturalism or the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
whereas this time i'm trying to be
entirely pedagogical and we're sticking
to what i mean by big ideas ideas that
are going to stick around essentially
forever ideas that we think play some
important correct role in describing the
world at least within some domain of
applicability physics ideas there are
also big ideas that are not part of
physics i don't have the expertise to
cover them so there's an implicit
physics
drop there into the title
but the point is that i'm not trying to
speculate there's nothing in there about
the further reaches of quantum mechanics
or the multiverse or extra dimensions or
dark matter particles or anything like
that this is the stuff that is we know
and is established and in in volume one
we're doing the classical physics stuff
but classical physics takes you pretty
far it takes you not only through newton
and galileo but up through einstein and
so we do special relativity general
relativity and black holes
the other special feature of this book
is that the equations are in there
so
there's plenty of books trying to
explain basic physics to you at
different levels of depth and
interestingness there are not a lot of
books that sit in the gap in between a
trade book which tries to be nothing but
words
analogies metaphors maybe some diagrams
trying to explain to you what's going on
versus textbooks that assume that you're
going to spend literally years studying
physics and eventually try to become a
professional physicist
i think that there is room to teach
people who don't necessarily want to
become professional physicists
what physics is really all about and if
you're really going to do that you need
to include the equations you need to
give the correct rigorous quantitative
formulation of the theory this is very
hard to do if you just kind of try to
water down an ordinary physics
curriculum because an ordinary physics
curriculum has that assumption behind it
that eventually you're going to be a
professional physicist so they're trying
to train you
to solve problems
in the most useful areas of physics that
a professional physicist might come
across
but if you don't want to be trained to
solve problems to literally solve the
equations if you just want to understand
the ideas
then it's way easier and i'm honestly
surprised that more other books haven't
done things like this so we just get to
the good stuff in this book we you do
have to understand the equations and i
try very hard to explain what the
equations say assuming you know nothing
more at the beginning than maybe
a little bit of familiarity with high
school algebra if you know x squared
means you're in good shape as far as
this book is concerned but then you
really get to just home in on what those
ideas are
and i think that the level of
understanding you get is better if you
have those equations in front of you
than if you're just being given some
words there's plenty of words that sound
good you know the analogies work and so
forth but the problem with analogies is
you can't extend them beyond their scope
and if you all you've done is hear the
analogy you don't know what that scope
is so really getting the correct
formulation of the theory i think is
very helpful and it's it's part of my
program to make sure that physics is
introduced into the wider cultural
context so that everyone has favorite
physics theories and are is talking
about them all the time so today in the
podcast what we're going to do is pick
out one of the highlights of the book
which is einstein's equation for general
relativity
you might think of einstein's equation
as e equals m c squared but that's not
right that is not the equation that
physicists call einstein's equation
einstein's equation for general
relativity is the equation that relates
the curvature of space-time to the
amount of energy and momentum in the
universe so it is the equation for
general relativity not for special
relativity the equation tells us how
gravity works
in a curved space-time background and
the math that you need to understand
that is a little bit advanced it's
considered advanced by uh math standards
for the podcast where i don't actually
get to show you equations and i don't
even get to draw diagrams we're not
going to explain in complete detail what
all the symbols mean but i will once
again stick to the spirit of the
operation in that i will try to
really explain
what is going on even though we will not
be deriving anything or explaining how
what the formulas are for defining all
these particular symbols i will tell you
exactly what they mean as as well as i
can in a set of words so that's what
this podcast is going to do and we'll
conclude with the payoff of
understanding why we think that there
are black holes how we solve einstein's
equation to actually show that there is
something that nobody expected to find
when einstein and his friends were first
thinking about these issues so it really
is a payoff and i hope that you stick
around to get to the end and hopefully
it makes some sense hopefully it gives
you a little bit of a deeper
understanding than you might have had
otherwise don't want to waste too much
time but i do want to take this
opportunity
to mention that the big picture
scholarship that is sponsored by
mindscape listeners is going great guns
we've gotten a number of
donations which i'm very very
appreciative of uh some big donations
which i'm very very very appreciative of
i'm not reading any anyone's name out
loud or anything like that to thank them
because i didn't ask them if that was
okay
but
rest assured if you're listening i am
very very appreciative and we've hit the
20 000 mark in donations to the
scholarship for those who don't know
this is a scholarship that we will be
awarding to
uh students who are undergraduate
college majors who are trying to study
the big picture the biggest ideas in the
universe as it were uh the nature of
space and time and existence and meaning
and life and complexity and all those
big questions so if you're a college
student who is interested in those kinds
of questions be sure to apply for the
scholarship and if you're past college
but think this is a good idea
be sure to donate you can go to bold.org
scholarships
mindscape bold.org is bold so bold.org
scholarship slash mindscape and we're
giving away ten thousand dollar
scholarships so the fact that we have
twenty thousand dollars in donations
means that this year we'll be giving
away two scholarships and if we get more
money in probably you won't make it to
30 000 but who knows you never know but
we'll just keep whatever money we have
for next year we're not gonna keep money
and put it into our pockets we're gonna
keep giving it away to deserving college
students so any that we have that is not
a multiple of 10k will be rolled over to
next year and i'm very excited to
sometime in early 2023 announce the
winners of the scholarships uh
scholarship plural now which is really
really good okay so with all that in
mind don't forget to buy the book if you
are so inclined the biggest ideas in the
universe space time in motion available
wherever there are books available there
is a
there are electronic editions kindle
editions and so forth there's also an
audio book that is narrated by me
um the audiobook does come with a pdf
that has a whole lot of equations in it
so don't feel left behind you'll be able
to look at the equations even if you're
an audiobook consumer so with that let's
go
[Music]
our self-appointed task today is to
understand the secrets of einstein's
equation and as i said it's not equals
mc squared it's the equation for general
relativity if you're curious as to what
the equation is
if you were to say it out loud it is r
mu nu minus one half r g mu nu equals
eight pi g t munu and if you stick
around for the rest of the podcast you
will know what that means even if you
don't know what it means now
secrets of einstein's equation isn't
really necessarily the best way of
describing it because after all
it's not a secret it's very easy to find
einstein's equation out there no one is
trying to keep it hidden from you but
it's effectively a secret because if you
haven't learned a lot of physics and a
lot of math you hear something like army
new minus one half rd mu equals eight pi
g team you knew and you're like that's
just gobbledygook right that doesn't
really mean anything and i have no idea
what that means
e equals mc squared which is an equation
that popped out of einstein's
formulation of special relativity in
1905
at least you can say well what do those
letters mean and someone tells you e
means energy m means mass c is the speed
of light and squared means you multiply
the speed of light by itself so energy
equals mass times the speed of light
squared now there's a subtlety there
because the physicists who talk about
this equation
know that it's a specific kind of energy
that is being talked about it's the rest
energy it's not the kinetic energy right
there's other kinds of energy that
objects can have we know that they have
kinetic energy if they're moving and
this equation equals mz squared has
nothing in it about moving right but
nevertheless
if
it has a meaning and that extra meaning
is that an object that is at rest not
moving
has a certain intrinsic energy and it
also doesn't depend on the potential
energy you know the height above ground
or the electrical charge of the object
or anything like that
so but nevertheless with all of these uh
caveats you can understand what that
equation means it's just a bunch of
things multiplied together how hard can
that be right
uh i am by the way when i when i say
things like that i know that i'm
exaggerating a little bit even
equations that have nothing but things
multiplied by each other can still be
hard i get that i'm just sort of joking
about the fact as i will continually do
that we're pretending these equations
are easy even though it does require a
little bit of effort but i do have a
philosophy that it doesn't require
an arbitrarily large amount of effort
you know it's just an equation
there are some equations that are
perfectly transparent when you say 2
plus 2 equals 4
i don't think anyone really that many
people anyway have trouble understanding
what that means and my philosophy here
is that
if you can understand two plus two
equals four
then you can understand e equals m c
square and for that matter you can
understand r mu nu minus one half r g mu
nu equals eight pi g t mu nu they're not
different in kind they're just different
in degree in sort of the degree of
abstraction and the complication and the
generality that they're trying to
address
but it's not like there's just a barrier
that some people just don't have it in
them to grasp these equations i i firmly
reject that at least for most people i
mean there might be some people who
are severely injured or whatever you
know or in a coma okay then maybe you
can't do it but i think that almost
everyone who you meet in your everyday
life and talk to as an ordinary person
could if they put their mind to it
understand what einstein's equation is
about that's really the motivating
philosophy behind the whole series of
books um the biggest ideas in the
universe and in the biggest ideas we go
through a lot of pre-relativity things
uh newton and space and time and force
and energy and all those things
leading up to general relativity at the
end of the book okay
so let's motivate what we're doing here
why are we interested in this other
equation if e equals m c squared was
part of special relativity that einstein
put together in 1905
our mu new minus one-half r g mu nu
equals eight pi g t mu nu is part of
general relativity which he put together
in 1915.
the difference and this is even
professional physicists sometimes get
this wrong sometimes the difference is
that
special relativity is a theory without
gravity
that's it that's the difference
sometimes you will hear that special
relativity is about unaccelerated
particles and you need general
relativity to describe accelerated
particles that is entirely nonsense
general relativity is a theory of
gravity special relativity is a theory
that says
space and time are both part of a single
four-dimensional space-time and the
speed of light is an absolute speed
limit within that space-time that's
special relativity and in principle you
could try to describe any number of
other forces in the context of special
relativity electromagnetism
fits perfectly well into special
relativity and in fact was the
inspiration for it electromagnetism was
put together in its current form in the
mid 19th century with maxwell and
faraday and all those folks and it was
realized that
electromagnetism a la maxwell has a set
of symmetries
that is different than what you might
have expected from newtonian mechanics
and trying to appreciate what those
symmetries are and how they fit
everything together led people including
einstein to come up with special
relativity einstein was really putting
the capstone on a long process that led
to that and equals mc squared was a tiny
little result that sort of came out as a
bonus and then for the next 10 years
from 1905 to 1915 einstein thought about
how to incorporate gravity into the
framework of special relativity and it
turned out to be a lot harder than he
expected so that's the story we're going
to tell today
so maybe a good starting point for that
story is gravity before einstein right
you've all heard of isaac newton
apparently an apple fell from a tree and
he noticed this apple and that led him
to invent gravity
now
everyone knew about gravity okay isaac
newton did not invent gravity that's not
the way that you should think about the
story and also apparently
that story of the apple falling was
promulgated by newton himself he this is
part of his uh burnishing his own
self-image and he was very interested in
making sure that everyone else gave him
credit for his genius ideas
but the context of the late 1600s was
people were trying to figure out why
planets in the solar system moved in
ellipses right kepler had already
described planetary motion using
ellipses very effectively but it was
just sort of a
guess you know so it's like okay maybe
they move an ellipses there is no
underlying mechanism for why it was
supposed to happen
and a lot of people understood that
probably gravity had something to do
with it and in fact people even
understood
that you could posit a law that said
that the gravitational force got less
and less as you got further away
as the inverse of the square of the
distance an inverse square law for
gravity this was not original with isaac
newton
the two things that newton did number
one is he showed how gravity could be
thought of as universal that's the point
of the apple falling the point of the
apple falling is not oh there's gravity
pulling apples down we knew that
the point was that a single law of
physics newton's law of gravity could
explain both the apples falling from the
tree and the planets moving around the
sun
the other thing that newton did is he
didn't just guess that an inverse square
law for gravity could explain the motion
of the planets he derived it he did the
calculations that was unambiguously
isaac newton's contribution here and of
course there's another thing he did
which is he he invented classical
mechanics which is very important to
making that derivation so anyway this is
the context 1600s isaac newton principia
mathematica was his book that he wrote
where he
gave everyone the rule for gravity
and derived the motion of the planets in
the context of
his theory of classical mechanics and
that theory of classical mechanics was
so good that people since the 1600s
basically took for granted that it was
exactly right and would be right forever
and it wasn't until the 19th century and
the beginnings of relativity and then
the 20th century with the flourishing of
relativity plus the invention of quantum
mechanics that newton's system was
really overturned
so classical mechanics is actually a
good place to start sort of to warm us
up for how to get to relativity and
einstein's equation and classical
mechanics is a subtle theory that many
books have been written about but
there's one equation for it that is by
far the one that you need to know i mean
physics professors joke about the fact
that if you know f equals m a you don't
really need to know everything else
anything else for the exam you're about
to take you could derive everything from
f equals m a
f equals ma is an even more important
equation a way more important equation
than e equals m c squared f equals m a
is newton's second law of motion the
first law just says that there's no
forces acting on something they will
move in a straight line
the second law of motion says if a force
does act on something what happens to it
and the answer is that it gets
accelerated okay so that's a very
logical sensible thing to say that if
you push on something if you act a force
on it it will start moving its velocity
will change it will accelerate
and it's even pretty sensible to say
that the acceleration depends on the
mass of the object okay if you have two
boxes sitting on the floor and you push
them with the same force if one of them
is empty and therefore relatively low in
mass the same force will get it going
much faster than a heavy box full of
books or something like that
i'm not just saying this because i
recently moved across the country and
have many books many boxes full of books
uh i've been experiencing newton's
second law up close and personal
recently
so it makes sense f equals ma the more
force you have the faster something
accelerates and it's the proportionality
constant is the mass so that's
part of why this equation is so great
force equals mass times acceleration the
force you act on something is equal to
its mass times its acceleration or if
you want to put it this way you could
divide both sides of that equation by
the mass
and say that the amount of acceleration
the object will undergo is the force you
act on it divided by the mass
that if you hear any tinkling in the
background that is caliban the little
kitty cat who is acting a force on the
mass of his little cat toy with that
which has a bell inside
so there are two things i want you to
appreciate about f equals m a newton's
second law of motion it's a it's a
genuine equation right so this is as
good a starting point as any to
appreciate why equations are so crucial
in doing physics this is almost a
question we don't really ask but let's
think about it
and one thing is that it is precise okay
it goes without saying so
f equals m a is not simply
translated into words as something like
the more force you push on something the
faster it will accelerate it's saying
that no doubt but it is saying something
absolutely precise and quantitative it's
not they're saying more force equals
more acceleration it's saying twice the
force equals precisely twice the
acceleration that's what it means to be
a proportionality
f is one
variable if you like it is the force
that might be different values depending
on how you're pushing on it
a the acceleration will be different
depending on how you push it and let's
for the current purposes assume that the
mass is just a fixed quantity okay
so then f equals m a is telling you that
as f changes a changes in lock step with
it
they are always related by the same
quantity m f always equals m a they
they're proportional to each other that
way
and then the other important thing about
the equation is it's universal
it applies over and over again it's not
just true for this box full of books
it's true for any box with or without
books anywhere in the universe okay so
it's not just i it's not just stating i
put a certain force on this box and it
accelerated by a certain amount it is
saying any time
that you put force on any object it will
start to accelerate and you can figure
out what the acceleration is
take the force divide by its mass okay
and that's really not so much a feature
of the equation as an equation as it is
a feature of the fact that
this equation is a law of physics that's
what makes the laws of physics so
powerful that they are rigorous
quantitative relationships between
different quantities in the universe
that become true over and over again
right so you can see how powerful that
is the motion of the planet saturn
around the sun can be explained by
saying there is a force acting on saturn
the force due to gravity caused by the
sun and that explains why saturn does
not go in a straight line or spiral
around because we know how it
accelerates and the answer is it
accelerates in such a way as to move it
on more or less an ellipse and that goes
true for all the other planets all the
other things in the solar system to the
extent that newtonian physics is true
so f equals m a is a great example of an
equation also a great example of a law
of physics there's one subtlety
about f equals m a that might be glossed
over if you just heard about it in a
trade book that was full of words but
since we're doing the equations here we
got to dig into the subtlety the
subtlety is that if you see the
correctly written out version of f
equals ma
there is a little arrow over the letter
f
and a little arrow over the letter a
there's no arrow over the letter m okay
so f with a little arrow equals m times
a with a little arrow that's really the
equation
what's going on with that well the
answer is that the quantities appearing
in the equation are not all created
equal
m the mass of the object that you're
pushing on that's just a number that's
once and for all a quantity it is three
kilograms or whatever it is
but f and a the force and the
acceleration are both vectors
they have both a magnitude how much
force or how much acceleration you have
but they also have a direction okay and
it turns out that if you get into the
rarefied land of super smart
mathematical thinking
you will think of a vector as
a vector that doesn't sound very
profound but what i mean is it's an
intrinsic kind of geometric object in
its own right and you don't say that you
know you don't write the vector in terms
of something else you just appreciate it
for its intrinsic vectorness
as opposed to what you and i are going
to be doing here today which is acting
like down to earth physicists and say
well how do you use this we want some
numbers that we can plug in we don't
want an abstract notion okay
and what that means is we think of the
vector as a collection of components of
the vector and this is a this is an
actual subtle move you know so far
everything i've said should be perfectly
obvious and even sort of tediously
boring but the idea of components of a
vector is a subtle and important one and
we're going to generalize it soon enough
so i want this to sink in
the idea is that because the vector has
not only a size but also a
directionality
if you want to express the vector you
want to write it down it's not as simple
as writing down the mass which is just
like three kilograms you have to express
both magnitude and the direction and
there's different ways of doing that but
a simple and very convenient one is to
set up a coordinate system and this is
again not a trivial move so i don't want
to act like it's no big deal but i'm
hoping that it makes sense when i say
the words set up a coordinate system so
at some point in space you choose it to
be the origin
of your coordinates and then you make
axes you make coordinate axes like x y
and z for example an x might be going
left right y might be going forward and
backward z might be going up and down
three perpendicular directions in space
okay
and the components of the vector is a
way of saying that we can think of any
vector pointing in any direction
as being a combination of
some amount of pointing in the x
direction
plus some amount of pointing in the y
direction plus some amount of pointing
in the z direction okay so those are the
components there's an x component to the
vector a y component and a z component
if the vector of the force that we're
pushing on for example if it happens to
be lining up in exactly the same
direction as the x-axis
so if the f vector is parallel to the
x-axis then the y-component and the
z-component of the vector will be zero
they still exist but their magnitudes
are zero for a more generic pointing
vector pointing in some combination it
will have a non-zero x component y
component and z component
so that equation f equals m a isn't just
an equation relating a number on the
left to a number on the right it's an
equation relating a vector on the left
the force is proportional
is equal to the mass times another
vector on the right the acceleration and
the way to think about that
in terms of components is there are
three numbers in three-dimensional space
that are telling you what vector you
have there's the x component the y
component of the z component okay so
rather than an equation between two
numbers f and m a
there's an there are three equations
there's a relationship between the x
component of the force and the x
component of the acceleration namely f
sub x equals m times a sub x
and likewise the y component of the
force is the mass times the y component
of the acceleration the z component of
the force is the mass times the z
component of the acceleration the mass
is the same in every single case but
there's either you can think of it
either way three different equations one
for the x component one for the y
component one for the z component of
force and acceleration or
if you
improve just a little bit in your
sophistication you think of it as a
single equation
relating two vectors written as sets of
three numbers so the way that you would
actually write this on a piece of paper
is a vertical column of numbers
three of them one of them is the x
component of the force the second one is
the y component of the force the third
number is the z component of the force
you put those in parentheses okay so a
little column of numbers three numbers
in parentheses f x f y f z
and you write that equals m times
another little column of numbers a x a y
a z the x component of the acceleration
the y component of the acceleration the
z component of the acceleration
so that's f equals m a in vector form
and very soon you're going to say well
okay that sounds okay i mean this maybe
you wouldn't say this but this is a
situation you'll find yourself in is
maybe i want to use a different
coordinate system right that's perfectly
okay coordinates are inventions of human
beings
this is something that should be pretty
obvious i just invented them i put the
origin down i put the x-axis the y-axis
the z-axis the coordinates aren't really
physically there
they are a useful construction to help
us human beings describe the situation
the real physical things that are there
like the mass and the acceleration and
the force okay
i emphasize this because in general
relativity in einstein's theory of
gravity in curved space time which he
put together in 1915
it becomes harder and harder to see
through the coordinates to the real
physical situation underneath and
einstein himself struggled with this and
many many super smart people struggled
with this
in general relativity more than any
other coordinate any other physical
theory it's very very important to
distinguish the physically real things
from the coordinate artifacts if you
want to put it that way and part of the
reason why that's so important is
because even though we set up x y and z
coordinates and we say yeah we just
invented them we could have used
different coordinates we could have used
polar coordinates or spherical
coordinates or whatever
nevertheless there's something that
seems very very natural about x y and z
coordinates these are called cartesian
coordinates after rene descartes okay
in general relativity will very often be
the case there are no natural
coordinates to use
you can think that something is natural
and telling you something is real but
it's really not all the coordinate
systems are created equal okay so all
this is to say
to make our lives easier rather than
writing f with a little vector sign
equals m a with a little vector sign or
rather than writing a column of three
quantities f x f y f z equals m times a
x a y a z
we will often write the whole equation
in terms of its components
with a little index
so if you want to think about that f
equals ma equation as three equations
one in the x direction one in the y
direction one in the z direction you can
just write f sub i
equals m times a sub i where f sub i is
any one of the three components the
letter i is an index that can take
values x y or z
so
f i equals m a i is a way of saying the
x component of the force is the mass
times the x component of the
acceleration likewise for the y
component likewise for the z component
so that's called writing the vector
equation in terms of components
and that will turn out to be very very
useful that is in fact what is going on
no reason to keep things secret until
the end right
when einstein's equation is expressed as
r mu nu minus one half r g mu nu equals
eight pi g t mu nu
why are those muse and news appearing
over and over again those are greek
letters the greek letter mu and the
greek letter nu and those are indices
why are we using greek letters rather
than i j k etc because they are indices
in space time
not in space
so f i the components of the force
vector are
components in space there's x and
there's y and there's z but once
relativity comes along we're going to
need space time coordinates so we have t
x y z time and then the three components
of space
and we group those four letters those
four components those four coordinates
together and we give them the letter mu
or new or rho or lambda or some other
greek letter we use greek letters to
denote coordinates on space-time just
like we use roman letters i j k to
denote coordinates in three-dimensional
space okay that was a little bit of a
looking ahead so f equals m a an
equation between two vectors we can
write it in components if we want to
what good is that this is newton's
second law of motion but by itself it
doesn't tell us what saturn does moving
around the sun okay
to understand that we need another
equation
and the other equation is the equation
that tells us what force is actually
acting on the object and that is
newton's inverse square law so the
inverse square law is the law that tells
us how the force of gravity stretches
over space the direction that the force
points in and also its magnitude and we
can write the inverse square law as f
with a little vector sign over it f
equals g times m1 times m2 over r
squared times e with a little vector
sign over it now what does all that mean
g capital g is newton's constant of
gravity
capital g is a constant of nature that
is telling us how strong the
gravitational field is
m1 and m2 that's m sub 1 and m sub 2 not
components of vectors
we use exactly the same kind of notation
to denote labels that distinguish
different particles in the universe as
well as different components sorry about
that there's only so many ways you can
push symbols around on a piece of paper
so m1 and m2
are the masses of
the two objects that are exerting
gravitational force on each other
r is the distance between them so it's g
m 1 m 2 over r squared and then e with
little vector sign is what we call a
unit vector it's just a vector pointing
from object to to object one and it
points in along the exactly the line
that is connecting those two objects
okay so it's just there telling us what
direction we're pointing in it has no
size in and of itself it's a unit vector
because its size is set equal to one
so this equation f equals g m one m two
over r squared times e vector
this is another vector equation it's
another equation of proportionality is
very much like f equals m a in fact if
you think about it if f equals m a
and f equals g m one m two over r
squared times e
then if that m in m a is let's say
m2 okay let's say that two object two is
saturn object one is the sun okay so
we're pushing on saturn the force due to
gravity from the sun is pushing on
saturn and that's m2
then
f equals m a which also equals g m1 m2
over r squared e vector
that means you can cancel out the m2s
there's an m2 and f equals m2a and
another m2 in gm1 m2 over r squared so
you cancel those out and what you get is
an equation for the acceleration a
of object number two
and it's very clear that's what is what
you use to figure out what the path of
object 2 is this is how the newtonian
paradigm works you tell me the initial
position
the initial velocity and i will give you
the force which tells you the
acceleration from that you can figure
out everything you can use calculus we
explained calculus in the book in the
biggest ideas book but i'm not going to
explain to you right now but you can use
calculus to solve for the entire motion
of saturn around the sun using that
input so that's how classical mechanics
works you have the second law of motion
f equals ma that relates force to the
physical acceleration of the object and
then you have some rule for what the
force actually is if it's the force of
gravity it's newton's inverse square law
goes as one over r squared and it's
again proportional to the mass
now i will parenthetically note because
this is going to be important in a
second the fact that the mass cancelled
out
is kind of interesting and cool isn't it
the there are two masses that appeared
in the law of gravity one for the sun
and one for saturn and if the question
we're asking is how does saturn move
around the mass of saturn appears both
in that expression and in f equals m a
but they cancel out when you set those
forces equal to each other so the answer
is that whatever the mass is
of the thing that gravity is acting on
doesn't matter
the acceleration of an object due to
gravity is independent of its mass the
force on it is not the force on the
object is proportional to the mass
but the acceleration is inversely
proportional to the mass and they
exactly cancel out
so this of course is the idea that
galileo promulgated a long time ago that
you can take two objects with different
masses
and as long as you can neglect air
resistance if you drop them they drop at
exactly the same speed
contra the long-standing previous idea
that heavier objects fall more rapidly
that's only because air resistance
usually doesn't affect the heavier
objects more the intrinsic acceleration
due to gravity on any two objects is the
same this is a special feature for
gravity
okay if you have something like the
force due to the electric field
it's absolutely not true that any two
objects feel the same acceleration due
to the electric field a an electrically
charged object will be pushed around by
an electric field whereas a neutral
object will not be pushed around at all
so gravity is universal
in a way that no other force is
and that was a feature of newton's
theory of gravity and newton remarked on
it but didn't really have an explanation
for it it will take center stage in
einstein's theory of gravity so let's go
there let's get there we have newtonian
gravity 1600s we can skip ahead quite a
lot of uh
interesting physics is being skipped
over but let's skip up to 1905. 1905 of
course was einstein's miraculous year he
was still young
not famous working in a patent office
but he published several papers on
quantum mechanics on brownian motion and
on also special relativity any one of
which should have won him the nobel
prize he only won one nobel prize but he
deserved more than one
so that year he did a lot of things one
of them was e equals m c squared he was
he was putting together this theory of
special relativity which as i said
other people had already made important
contributions to lorentz and fitzgerald
and poncare and others had said very
important things along the road to
special relativity
and what einstein really did was take
the final step the maybe i should say
the penultimate step the lat second to
last step
and that step which is a really crucial
one was to say
there's no such thing as the ether
what people were trying to do in that
development of special relativity was
reconcile
the apparent
signal that they were getting from
maxwell's equations of electromagnetism
that a special role was being played by
the speed of light
with the fact that in newtonian
mechanics there's no velocity that has
any special role at all so they posited
the existence of ether of this invisible
stuff through which electromagnetic
waves travel and they tried to detect it
and turns out you can't detect it no
experiment was telling you anything
so they kept tweaking the theory in
interesting ways to try to sort of
make the ether less and less detectable
and they succeeded at doing that and it
was einstein's insight to say look the
real secret is there isn't any ether
just get rid of it
now to make sense of how to do that you
have to radically change your notion of
space and time okay so that's why
special relativity is kind of a big deal
and einstein was very smart as you may
have heard so he appreciated this and
that's where you get stories about
length contraction time dilation all of
that stuff as you move close to the
speed of light that is what einstein
really talked about when he invented
special relativity but he didn't in 1905
take the very last step along the road
to special relativity the very last step
was by hermann minkowski
probably should be minkowski but i'm
going to pronounce it using an american
pronunciation uh minkowski had been
einstein's old professor i think in
zurich but i'm not 100 sure but einstein
had taken classes from minkowski they
weren't that different in age but
mikowski was a little bit older
unlike einstein who was a brilliant
physicist minkowski was a mathematician
and minkowski read his old students
papers and thought about them and it was
benkowski who came up with the insight
that really what einstein had discovered
was space-time
okay einstein in 1905 never talked about
space-time he never said that his theory
of relativity was a way of thinking of
space and time as part of a single
underlying space time that was minkowski
in 1907.
so in 1907 minkowski says
the right way to think about special
relativity is
space space-time is the four-dimensional
world in which we live you could have
talked about space-time before
relativity came along right you had
space you had time they both existed in
newtonian mechanics they both have a
separate absolute reality to them
but minkowski says
no they don't not in special relativity
instead there's only four-dimensional
space-time which you and i
choose to divide up into space and time
and he has a great quote about it he
says henceforth space by itself
and time by itself are doomed to fade
away into mere shadows and only a kind
of union of the two will preserve an
independent reality
so this is the sign of one of the
various signs of being a good scientist
you not only figure something out but he
understood the implications
of it okay and he says right up there
right
front and center there is no space there
is no time there is only space time that
is a better way of thinking about
what einstein had established with
special relativity now it's worth noting
parenthetically one person who was not
impressed by this insight was albert
einstein
again he was a physicist at heart not a
mathematician and in fact in one of his
papers soon thereafter soon after
minkowski's paper einstein says
mckelsey's formulation makes rather
great demands on the reader in its
mathematical aspects and then he chooses
then he goes on to ignore it basically
so basically einstein's first reaction
was
this is just sort of mathematical
abstraction fuzziness has nothing to do
with the real world but soon he'll be
hoist on his own petard we'll show you
that einstein had to come around to the
uh space-time way of thinking
so what did minkowski mean
what did he mean by saying that you
should think about space-time as a
single thing rather than space and time
separately well let's think about space
okay let's really get space straight in
our heads and then we will be able to
uh generalize it to space-time
the way that we thought about space
comes down to us all the way from euclid
right euclidean geometry uh the geometry
of a tabletop or ordinary
three-dimensional euclidean space around
us
and there are rules in euclidean
geometry like pythagoras theorem and so
forth now in the 1800s people had
already begun investigating
non-euclidean geometries but let's start
with the euclidean geometry okay flat
geometry the kind of geometry that works
if you draw figures on a tabletop
and
maybe arguably one of the central
features of euclidean geometry is as we
mentioned pythagoras's theorem
pythagoras's theorem says if you have a
right angle triangle
then the distance the the length of the
hypotenuse the long side of the triangle
is related to the length of the shorter
side by long side squared equals sum of
the other two sides squared so c squared
equals a squared plus b squared if c is
the hypotenuse the long side of the
triangle and a and b are the shorter
sides
why is this so very important well it
goes back to our construction of
coordinates on space time right sorry i
said space time thinking relativity i
meant space just think about coordinates
on space x y and z
pythagoras theorem gives us a very easy
way to think about the length of any
straight line
in euclidean geometry give me any two
points in euclidean geometry okay in
three dimensional space
what is the distance between them well
build a coordinate system around them
and there will be a a displacement of
the two points in the x direction call
it x
a displacement in the y direction y and
a displacement in the z direction z
and a three-dimensional version of
pythagoras's theorem would tell you that
the distance d
between the two points
obeys d squared equals x squared plus y
squared plus z squared okay there's a
three-dimensional right triangle
that describes the straight line
connecting any two points in euclidean
geometry so that pythagorean theorem is
sort of a souped-up way of thinking
about
giving you distances of curves straight
lines in particular but then
using calculus you could take any curvy
curve
and zoom in on it and the whole point of
calculus is that if you zoom in on a
curve it looks like a straight line
so calculus lets you build up the
distance along a curve by treating an
infinitesimally tiny part of that curve
as a straight line
calculating its distance
as
dx squared plus d y squared plus dz
squared the little infinitesimal
coordinate displacements adding them up
and taking the square root okay so
really pythagoras theorem lets you
calculate the length of any kind of
curve in euclidean geometry it really
can be thought of as serving as the
basis of all euclidean geometry there
are other
features of euclidean geometry like the
fact that you know the area inside a
circle is pi r squared
but you can derive all that from the
very basic formalisms that start with
pythagoras theorem and this is why
minkowski says you should think about
space-time as a single thing because he
says you can rederive
all of the results of special relativity
by generalizing that formula
distance squared equals x squared plus y
squared plus z squared by generalizing
it to space time
but there's a clever little switch that
comes in there and i will tell you what
that switch is so think about the twin
paradox i hate calling the twin paradox
because it's not a paradox uh it's a
thought experiment the twin thought
experiment and you've probably heard of
this before
two twins so they're exactly the same
age roughly but not exactly but they're
roughly the same age because they're
twins
and one of them stays home
doesn't leave the earth just sits around
lives their life the other one hops in a
spaceship and goes out near the speed of
light and then comes back okay
and the prediction of special relativity
which has been verified in various
indirect ways is that the age of the
twin who goes back goes out on the
rocket ship and then comes back
will be noticeably less if they went out
near the speed of light when they return
than the age of the twin who stayed
behind
in other words slightly more
carefully the elapsed time along the
path that zooms out close to the speed
of light and then zooms back is less
than the elapsed time of the person who
just stayed behind
now this
should maybe ring a tiny bit of a bell
because you know that in good old
euclidean geometry in space there is a
maxim that says the shortest distance
path between any two points is a
straight line
if you give me any two points in space i
can construct all sorts of curves
connecting them literally an uncountably
infinite number of curves connecting
them but there is a unique one that has
the shortest distance along it and it
happens to be the one that we call
straight
so when you have two points in euclidean
space when you say the distance between
them you are implicitly meaning the
distance along the shortest path the
straight line path but distances along
other paths are uniformly going to exist
and be longer
any non-straight path has a longer than
the shortest possible distance so
minkowski is saying something like that
is exactly what's going on in the twin
thought experiment except there is a
minus sign
that sneaks in the right way to think
about the twin thought experiment is the
twin who stays back on earth is more or
less moving on a straight line in space
time
the twin who gets in the rocket is not
moving in a straight line they move in a
straight line in the first
segment of their journey but then they
turn around and come back so their path
as a whole is bent they're when they
turn around and come back okay
and they experience less time and no
matter what they do no matter what kind
of path they took if they like went in
spirals or whatever did crazy different
things
the twin who goes out and does not move
on a straight line always experiences
less time
so the time you experience
is kind of like the distance along a
curve the time you experience in space
time is analogous to the distance of a
curve the length of a curve in euclidean
geometry
except with the new rule that instead of
saying the shortest distance path is a
straight line
it's the longest time elapsed is a
straight line in
space time
so the personal time that you experience
what relativists would call the proper
time the time that actually clicks off
on your wristwatch or your smartphone or
whatever
is
different in special relativity than it
was in newtonian in the newtonian world
because the newtonian world time is just
absolute
everyone agrees on what time is and
everyone experiences the same amount of
time
but in relativity everyone experiences
their own personal time and that
personal time will depend on the path
they take through space-time in our
everyday world we don't notice because
it only becomes a noticeable feature if
your velocities are differing from each
other at
magnitudes that are close to the speed
of light
we move slowly with respect to each
other in the everyday world so we never
noticed that's why you had to be
einstein to invent this theory but the
idea is that what you and i think of as
the elapsed time
is kind of like the distance on a curve
except that instead of being longer and
longer the curvier your path is the
shorter and shorter the less and less
time you feel
and so minkowski being a well-trained
mathematician was able to turn that into
an equation
so just as we had the equation in
euclidean geometry that if you have two
points in space separated by x y and z
the distance between them obeys distance
squared equals x squared plus y squared
plus z squared
minkowski says take two points in space
time they are now
separated in time as well as in space so
by an amount t as well as an amount x
and y and z because two points in space
time might be located at different
points in space and different points in
time
and he says if you travel
between them between those two events in
space time the elapsed time squared
because it's a pythagoras-like kind of
relation so the elapsed times squared is
t squared
minus x squared minus y squared minus z
squared
so it's kind of like pythagoras
pythagoras says x squared plus y squared
plus z squared
minkowski says t squared minus that
minus x squared minus y squared minus z
squared and this is the minkowski metric
on spacetime this is a way of measuring
intervals in space-time it's not the
euclidean way the euclidean way would be
plus plus plus x squared plus square
plus y squared plus z squared the
minkowski way is plus minus minus minus
plus t squared minus x squared minus y
squared minus z squared okay
and from that simple idea
that what you and i experience as time
elapsing is a geometric quantity that
will depend on the path you take through
space-time
that's the origin of all of special
relativity you can derive all that stuff
about
length contraction and time dilation and
all that kind of thing okay all from
this single idea that minkowski had that
you put a minus sign and otherwise
elapsed times are kind of like distances
traveled but in space-time not in space
so einstein was you know unimpressed he
thought he understood special relativity
pretty well himself but you know okay
minkowski to the mathematicians had made
a great advance in a sort of conceptual
way of thinking about special relativity
what einstein cared about was a much
more tangible problem to him which is
that gravity didn't fit into special
relativity you know when newton came
along with ordinary newtonian mechanics
the very first thing he did you know the
thing that made him money was
using it to predict the
planets moving around the sun
under the force of gravity right when
you have a new theory of mechanics the
first thing you want to do is figure out
how gravity works in it
and so when you come up with relativity
electromagnetism fits into it very very
nicely but newtonian gravity didn't so
you were going to have to change
newton's theory of gravity a little bit
okay how hard can that be right well
turns out to be really super duper hard
and einstein was sad he thought about it
a lot he used his brain
and what he went back to
was that feature of newtonian gravity
which is that the mass cancels out
the mass of the object that is falling
under the force of gravity doesn't
affect its acceleration because it
affects both the force and the
acceleration in the same exact way
so gravity has this feature of being
universal and what einstein did was he
sort of
generalized that fact that two objects
will fall at the same rate in a
gravitational field
to
a wider claim which he called the
principle of equivalence
and the principle equivalent says let's
say that you were in a gravitational
field but you're in a sealed room so you
can't see outside okay
so you feel the force of gravity because
gravity
stretches through the room you still
follow the floor even if your room is
sealed and you can do experiments you
can you know drop objects and measure
the force of gravity and you measure the
charge of the electron whatever physics
experiments you want to do
and einstein says imagine that you are
in a rocket ship
and the rocket ship is very very quiet
the engine makes almost no noise at all
and the rocket ship is accelerating at
one g
at exactly the same acceleration as the
force of gravity and you're sealed
inside a room in the rocket ship and you
are also allowed to do experiments you
can drop objects you can time them you
can measure the charge the electron
whatever you want
einstein says that there is no
experiment you can do at least in a
small enough region of space-time that
could possibly distinguish being in a
gravitational field
versus being in no gravitational field
but accelerating
and that's obviously only possible
because gravity is universal you could
clearly distinguish whether you were in
an electric field or not because a
charged particle and an uncharged
particle would respond differently to
the electric field but everything
responds to gravity in the same way
therefore you don't know if gravity even
exists okay
now you or i had we come up with this
thought experiment we'd be very proud of
ourselves we'd tell our friends but we
would probably stop there einstein being
einstein
went way further
he said i know what this means i know
what this implies what this implies is
the reason why gravity
is not
as easy to reconcile with special
relativity as electromagnetism was
is because gravity isn't a force
like
electric force or magnetic force r in
the sense that gravity doesn't live on
top of space-time gravity is universal
therefore says einstein we should think
of gravity as a feature of space-time
rather than as a force field living
inside of it
gravity is different because it's
something about space-time itself so you
can see he bought into this whole
space-time idea that minkowski had right
and i said okay i guess i gotta i gotta
under gotta put up with this even if it
is sort of challenging and making
demands on the reader in its
mathematical aspects
so einstein says okay
i'm gonna say that gravity is a feature
of space-time
what feature could it be
well
minkowski when he proposed his idea of
unifying space and time into space-time
thought of it as basically geometry
right you're modifying euclidean
geometry to be something else to be what
you might call minkowski in geometry
these days it is more often called
lorenzian geometry but i think minkowski
should get the credit for it honestly
lorentz also did other good things but
he didn't really think about the
geometry of space-time
anyway so in this minkowski in geometry
you have a modification of pythagoras
theorem uh with the minus signs in it
and einstein thought about that and he
said yeah okay you know
space-time is not only a thing but it's
a thing with a geometry
and i am looking for features of that
thing space-time that could serve the do
the work of being gravity
so
the obvious thing to guess once you've
gone through all these steps which are
not at all obvious the obvious thing is
to say the geometry
maybe space time could be curved not
only have some minus signs in the metric
that help explain how space and time get
involved in the distances traveled but
maybe that
space time could be curved in some
interesting way in some non-trivial way
maybe the sun
acts to curve space-time around it
and all saturn is doing is trying to
move in a straight line the best it can
but there are no straight lines because
space-time is curved
and you and i experience and think of
that effect of space-time curvature as
gravity this was einstein's brilliant
idea you know i i've just stated it
using
usual sentences that physicists say i
don't actually know what was going on in
einstein's mind very well i mean it's
clearly quite a leap of imagination to
get there it was very very impressive
that he put all that together
the problem was
einstein didn't understand anything
about geometry not at the level that he
needed to to do this kind of problem he
was not a mathematician remember that's
not what he was a specialist in he
learned only the mathematics that he
needed to learn in order to do physics
and
the geometry of general curve spaces and
space times was not one of the subjects
that he ever needed to study the good
news is he was very good friends with a
guy named marcel grossman
grossman was a fellow student of
einstein's actually helped him get his
first job and grossmann was a
mathematician he did know all the
newfangled work in geometry and so forth
and so
einstein sat down to learn
non-euclidean geometry from marshall
grossman unfortunately for him it was a
few just a few decades earlier in the
1800s that that had all been worked out
people had invented non-remoni
non-euclidean geometry i gave away the
guy who did the most important work
there riemann
um people had invented non-ukrainian
geometry and they'd been thinking about
it so the technology was there
ready and uh available for einstein to
use he didn't have to invent it himself
so what are we what do we mean by the
technology here so
euclid
was euclidean geometry that serves as
the basis for pythagoras theorem and the
area is pi r squared and all that stuff
okay
you might remember the story of euclid
and his postulates
the great advance of euclidean geometry
wasn't pythagoras theorem because
pythagoras had already come up with his
theorem they already knew that
the thing that euclid really did was to
write geometry as an axiomatic system
he said if you believe this and this and
this these so-called axioms you just
postulate them they're postulates or
axioms same thing
if you postulate these things you can
derive all these results like the areas
pi r squared like pythagoras theorem all
those other things and that that sort of
set a way to do mathematics that we
still use today you have some postulates
or some axioms you derive some theorems
from them
and for the most part euclid's
postulates for
geometry were pretty straightforward
right
through any
two points you can draw a line things
like that things that you really
wouldn't argue with um through any one
point you can always draw a line i think
it was one of the postulates uh
but
there was one postulate the fifth one
euclid's fifth postulate which is called
the parallel postulate that just seemed
a little bit more
specific than others it was like a
little bit less obvious and for many
many years people thought well maybe
it's not supposed to be an axiom or a
postulate maybe it's supposed to be a
theorem maybe you could derive it
you can't as it turns out so what is the
statement of the parallel postulate
basically the rough idea is
parallel lines remain parallel forever
that's the idea okay remain the same
distance apart
to be a little bit more specific what do
you mean by parallel lines right so
think about a two-dimensional plane that
we're working on so forget about three
dimensions for a second so you're
working on the tabletop or something
like that
first draw a straight line segment a
little tiny straight line segment okay
and then at the ends of the line segment
draw two lines perpendicular both
perpendicular to the original line
segment and those two lines move off in
the same direction and we call those
initially parallel lines hopefully you
can visualize this visualize this in
your head one little line segment is the
base and then there's two
straight lines going off infinitely far
at right angles initially to the first
line segment so those start out as
parallel lines
and the parallel postulate is just the
statement that they remain parallel
forever that is to say if you take the
distance between them on a straight line
that is perpendicular to both that
distance remains the same distance they
remain the same distance apart that's a
very sensible thing to believe and
euclid wrote it down and postulate
but no one could ever prove it so it
remained a postulation
it took a long time
for people to realize that the reason
you couldn't prove it is because it
doesn't have to be true
that is to say and this is really the
beginning of
a lot of what mathematicians still do to
this day they say what happens if i
replace this postulate with a different
postulate
so in particular
a couple of mathematicians loboszewski
and boli and also arguably carl
friedrich gauss who was the most famous
mathematician of the time but he didn't
like to write things down so he didn't
write this one down so he doesn't get
credit for it lobazewski and bolyai said
look what if i replace
the postulate that these initially
parallel lines stay the same distance
apart with a new postulate that says
these initially parallel lines gradually
diverge
they grow further and further apart
turns out you can take that new
postulate add it to the other existing
postulates of euclid and get a perfectly
good version of geometry it's not the
version of geometry that you and i know
and love in this new version
in a triangle the sum of the angles
inside is always less than 180 degrees
you know that in euclidean geometry the
sum of the interior angles is always
exactly 180 degrees
in the new geometry that boli and
lebashevsky invented it's always less
than 180 degrees the area of a circle is
not pi r squared it is always greater
than pi r squared etc there's slight
changes to everything that you knew and
loved about good old-fashioned euclidean
geometry and this geometry that was
invented is called hyperbolic geometry
and there's another geometry you can
invent which is to say that instead of
the lines diverging maybe they converge
that's another kind of geometry and in
that geometry with the converging lines
initially parallel the area of a circle
of radius r is always less than pi r
squared
the sum of the triangles inside is
always greater than 180 degrees etc so
you change in little interesting ways
all of the usual things about geometry
and you might say well you know
spherical geometry that's called
spherical geometry when the lines are
coming together
that makes sense to me it's like what
happens on the surface of a sphere the
hyperbolic geometry is harder to
visualize but it's kind of like what is
on the surface of a potato chip a
pringle or also on the surface of a
saddle there's a subtlety here because
you can make a perfectly good sphere
inside three-dimensional euclidean space
that's why i think
spherical geometry was not invented
first because people didn't think of it
as a different kind of geometry they
just thought of spheres as being
embedded in good old three-dimensional
euclidean space
but it turns out that the hyperbolic
plane
that a two-dimensional surface that
obeys the axioms of hyperbolic geometry
cannot be embedded
inside three-dimensional euclidean space
so this was really an example of
mathematicians inventing a geometry
based on axioms that you couldn't make
you couldn't construct it exactly the
pringle or the saddle are approximations
to it but they're not exactly the same
thing this exists only in the minds of
mathematicians this hyperbolic plane
which is very interesting so people got
excited by that
gauss got excited by it
even though he claimed to do it first uh
but he knew that it wasn't the end of
the story because for a couple reasons i
mean even though hyperbolic geometry was
different than good old euclidean
geometry it was still very limited and
specialized right it's still only two
dimensions
and even more importantly
that there's a single kind of curvature
going on and the difference between
euclidean geometry and non-euclidean
geometry is that in a euclidean geometry
space is flat
there's no curvature anywhere that's
kind of what it means to say that
initially parallel lines remain parallel
the this hyperbolic plane or the sphere
are curved and that curvature pushes the
lines together or apart
and you can see how this is kind of
suggestive for einstein who wants the
curvature of space-time to push objects
around and we call that gravity okay but
the assumption of hyperbolic geometry
was that there was only one way
in which the lines diverge and that they
diverge at the uniform rate no matter
what direction you go in so it was very
very specific very very generalized
and bernard riemann
around 1854
was a student of gauss and he had
already got his phd but the germans you
know they have another degree you need
to get before you're able to teach in
universities and so riemann goes to
gauss and says what should i work on for
my next degree
and
gauss said well come up with a list of
possibilities and i'll pick one so
riemann goes back and he comes up with a
list of possibilities and gauss picked
what riemann thought was the most boring
one
which is
the
foundations of geometry
okay because gauss knew that you know we
now had non-euclidean geometries but we
weren't done yet figuring out how
geometry worked and furthermore there
was one looming crutch that gauss wanted
to remove from the whole
system which is that we think of this
sphere or this hyperbolic plane we
always look at it from the outside
right we're not talking about the
intrinsic geometry of a space we're
looking at it from the point of view of
someone who is not embedded inside
and so riemann set himself the task of
thinking about how would you
talk about the geometry of a surface or
even a higher dimensional space
if
you had to live inside it you were not
allowed to refer to it from the outside
in any way
well the idea that he came up with was
the metric
that is to say riemann says if you are
able to tell me
the length of any curve that i can draw
then you know everything there is to
know about the geometry of the space
there might be other ways to specify the
geometry but he says if if you can tell
me the lengths of curves in a perfectly
general way then i can figure everything
else out
that was his brilliant idea
and so that harkens back to what
minkowski did of course minkowski did
after riemann did it and mikowski did it
for space time riemann did it in perfect
generality so what does that mean what
does it mean to
be given or be able to calculate the
length of every single possible curve
well we already gave away
half of the answer which is calculus
okay
you don't need to
says riemann you don't need to literally
draw every curve and tell me its length
what you need to do is to give me every
little tiny bit of curve so at every
point in space i can imagine drawing a
little line segment very very very tiny
and riemann says give me the formula for
the length
of that line segment give me the
generalization of pythagoras theorem
it's not just going to be x squared plus
y squared plus z squared it might be
something more complicated because my
coordinates might be different
space itself might be curved he wasn't
thinking about space time just space so
x y z
he says give me the formula for the
length as a function of x and y and z
for every infinitesimal line segment at
every point in space
from that
i can build up everything i can build up
the entire geometry of the space
so what does that mean like what are
what are the actual pieces of
information you need to calculate the
length of a little tiny line segment
well if you think about pythagoras so
the distance squared is x squared plus y
squared plus z squared
what that's saying is you give me x
twice there are three coordinates x y
and z
you give me x and x to get the x squared
part y and y to get the y squared part
and z and z to get the z z squared part
but in a perfectly general coordinate
system
you know think about it this way what if
you drew just x and y coordinates but
they weren't perpendicular to each other
what if you drew the y coordinate at an
angle compared to where you usually draw
it
then the formula for a little length
would also involve not only x squared
and y squared but x times y there'd be a
contribution
that would sort of change the overall
distance from crosstalk between the x
and y coordinates because x moves in a
direction that is not perpendicular to
what y does okay
so what riemann says is
what you're going to have to give me is
for every pair of coordinates there will
be a number so for x comma x there's a
number for x comma y there's a number
for x comma z there's a number for y
comma y etc if you have three
coordinates there are nine numbers
and you give me these nine numbers and i
can use those to construct the
generalization of pythagoras theorem
so instead of distance squared is x
squared plus y squared plus z squared
distance squared is some number times x
squared
plus some number times x times y plus
some number times x times z
plus some number times
y times x
plus some number times y times y etc
okay a nine
a three by three array of numbers
that encodes all of the information
about the distance of any curve you
might ever want to draw and this is
where it's harder to do an audio because
you can't see me draw it but basically
you have three coordinates and for each
pair of coordinates you give me a number
so that forms a little matrix as we call
it a little three by three array of
numbers and these arrays of numbers are
what tell you how to calculate distances
in a completely arbitrary geometry with
a completely arbitrary set of
coordinates
and that array of numbers is called the
metric
tensor metric for measurement right
you're measuring how long things are
and tensor because it is a
generalization of a vector remember we
said that vectors can be thought of as a
little column of three numbers
so rather than just working with single
numbers like mass and so forth sometimes
in geometry you have to work with
vectors that have three numbers required
to specify them like the force like the
acceleration
the metric in riemann's way of thinking
about it you need nine numbers to
specify it in a three-dimensional space
in an n-dimensional space you need n
numbers and sorry n-squared numbers to
specify the metric so in
four-dimensional space-time we're going
to need 16 numbers 4 by 4 to specify it
and instead of thinking as little column
of numbers you think of it as a square
array of numbers
that would be the 3x3 metric in three
dimensional space the metric tensor okay
and i'm not going to fill in all the
details but riemann s he actually
let me let me back up on that a little
bit i was gonna say riemann tells you
that you can do everything with that
metric and it's true he did kind of tell
you that but he didn't actually tell you
how to do everything if you read
riemann's original paper it was a little
sketchy
and riemann very tragically died at a
fairly young age but his task was taken
up by a bunch of other people richie and
uh
christophel and levi chivita and other
people and they developed all of this
beautiful tensor analysis
for curved surfaces and curved spaces
and we call it altogether riemannian
geometry even though it was not all
there in riemann's original paper
anyway so where are we
the idea is that
riemann says that in any geometry not
just euclidean geometry not just
hyperbolic geometry not just spherical
geometry but any geometry so you can
have arbitrary bends and wiggles
anywhere in space doing different things
he says i can completely characterize
that by giving you the metric tensor by
giving you this three by three or four
by four in space time array of numbers
that tells you how to calculate the
length of a curve and that's really good
because that's exactly what minkowski
said you need it in space time except
it's a space time metric so there's some
minus signs scattered around there but
otherwise it's exactly the same it's a
four by four array of numbers the space
time metric and there's some minus signs
in there because it's space time not
space but it's the same basic idea okay
so this is what grossman taught to
einstein and einstein knew about the
principle equivalent so he's like yes
we're on the right track
but there is a little bit of a
distinction here between the metric
which is sort of telling you what the
geometry is and what you want to know
about the geometry okay you know in
principle
all the information about the geometry
is
implicit in that metric it is it is
embedded in there if you give me the
metric at every single point in space or
every single point in space time
in principle i can figure out what it is
i want
but maybe i just want to characterize
what it is i want directly maybe i don't
want to do all that work so in
particular
maybe what i want to know if i'm
einstein is
how is space-time curved
so the metric is enough to determine the
curvature of space-time but it's not
quite so simple as telling you the
curvature of space-time directly why
because the metric by itself could be
any numbers that just depends on the
coordinate system and we've already
emphasized that the coordinate system
isn't important the coordinate system is
not physical
okay
there are other things that are physical
and so we want to take that metric which
depends on what coordinates you use
maybe not x y z
maybe r theta phi if you have spherical
coordinates or something like that okay
you want to extract from that metric
what the curvature is and also the
curvature depends not on the metric at
any one point but how the metric is
changing from point to point the
warpings the bendings that's what the
curvature is so it's a different kind of
thing
okay
how do we specify the curvature of an
arbitrary space-time uh says professor
riemann and his successors
well if you would think about it
the parallel postulate of euclid said if
you have a little line segment and you
start two lines perpendicular from it
initially parallel they will stay
parallel boli and lobazewski and gauss
said well what if we let them diverge or
converge we would get non-euclidean
geometries
so
maybe
and in fact yes
what if i told you
at every point in space
for every line segment i could draw
and for every
set of two lines i could send off
perpendicular to that line segment
how would the distance between them and
the orientation between them change
okay that was a lot to say so i'm going
to try to say it again i draw a little
line segment
i take two sides of the line segment the
two points at the end i
take two vectors that are pointing
perpendicular to the line segment at
each end and i follow the curves that i
get by moving straight as straight as i
can away from the initial line segment
there will be some distance between them
some other vector that tells me how i'm
connecting one
parallel initially parallel line to the
other one and that can get bigger or
smaller and it can twist around and do
all sorts of things
that will be a manifestation of
curvature all the ways in which those
two initially parallel lines fail to be
equidistant at all times
are manifestations of curvature
so that's okay that's good i mean this
is you know we're glossing over a lot of
things it took me a long time to get
here okay this is not immediately
obvious stuff
but
the point is that that's a lot of
information you're telling me for every
line segment you can draw
and then for every line segment you can
draw for every direction perpendicular
to that line segment because there's
going to be a lot of different
directions you could go in a space that
is more than three-dimensional or more
than two-dimensional rather
so for space-time if i give you a point
and a line segment there's a lot of
other line segments that are
perpendicular to the original one
so for every line segment i can draw for
any orientation of it for any other
orientation perpendicular to it there is
yet another
vector which is how the two initially
parallel lines are moving apart or
moving together or twisting right so
it's a lot of information
so it turns out that all this
complicated information is summed up in
yet another tensor
but this tensor is not
four by four like the metric tensor in
space time is four by four array of
numbers because it's four dimensions of
space four components okay
the riemann tensor
is four by four by four by four
that is to say we write it as r
capital r for riemann and then it has
four indices and they're greek indices
because we're working in space time so
we might write it as r lambda rho mu nu
rather than just g mu nu for the metric
r lambda rho mu nu four indices four
times four times four times four numbers
components 256 components all told in
the riemann tensor in four dimensions
and who says you have to be in four
dimensions right you could be in more
dimensions than that you could be in any
number of dimensions and there would
still be a riemann tensor and they could
still have more and more components but
to mathematicians this is nothing like
once you had the idea of making tensors
by adding on new indices
having four indices rather than two
indices makes no difference whatsoever
it's just a tensor with more slots to it
now to graduate students taking general
relativity who have to calculate the
riemann tensor that's harder work
there's a lot of components to calculate
256 of them in principle happily there's
not really nearly that many because many
of them are very very simply related to
each other or some of them are exactly
zero automatically but still it's a lot
of work the good news is what do you
mean to calculate the riemann tensor
well remember the setup the setup is
the geometric information is contained
in the metric
so for every little tiny line segment at
every point you tell me how to calculate
its distance that's a tensor g mu nu 4x4
array of quantities
from the metric you can calculate the
riemann tensor even though the riemann
tensor has a lot more components you
take derivatives of the metric to see
how the metric is changing from point to
point the rate of change of the metric
from point to point and from those in
all the different directions you can
move you calculate the riemann tensor
okay so it's much like if you want to
know on a landscape that you're going to
walk on
how
what is the angle at which you're
walking right up a hill or something
like that well you could be given the
data of the landscape in terms of the
height above ground at every point and
you would have to calculate the slope of
the landscape at every point so you
could do that that's what it means to
take a derivative how much is the height
changing from place to place that's the
relationship between the metric tensor
and the riemann tensor the riemann
tensor it turns out is just a compact
way of thinking about how the metric is
changing from place to place and that
characterizes the curvature
okay all that is the story that was told
by marcel grossman to albert einstein
and so einstein who's the physicist here
his job is to turn it into physics
we did a lot of math there's a metric
giving you distances there's the riemann
tensor giving you curvature
einstein wants the curvature to reflect
the force of gravity how is that going
to happen how is that going to lead us
to einstein's equation well
think back hearken back to newton newton
had a theory of gravity after all and
for him the source of gravity was the
mass of the object right the source of
the gravitational pull due to the earth
is the mass of the earth if the earth
were heavier there'd be more gravity
it's also dependent on the distance but
it's the mass that is causing the
initial gravitational pull
likewise the sun has a lot more mass so
it has a lot more gravity
but einstein knew better you know you
might say okay so mass is going to be
the source of gravity so mass causes
space time to curve but einstein had
already invented e equals m c squared
right so
that equation e equals m c squared is an
example of unification
it's an example where in physics we take
two different ideas and we learn that
they're different aspects of a single
underlying concept and the way to think
about e equals m c squared is that what
mass is
is a form of energy
it's one of the forms that energy can
take there can also be kinetic energy
potential energy whatever
but one form that energy can take is
mass namely when the object is just
sitting there not doing anything its
energy is
its mass times the speed of light
squared
but there are other forms that energy
can take and so
energy is more fundamental than mass in
that sense but there's more unification
that comes along equals mc squared is
not the only equation in special
relativity
as you unify space and time
you also unify energy and momentum you
know momentum
is a quantity that refers to how fast
you're moving in the simple newtonian
way of thinking momentum is just mass
times velocity
whereas the kinetic energy is one half
mv squared the velocity squared but in
relativity they're related to each other
energy is kind of like the time-like
version of momentum which makes sense
because there's one dimension of time
three dimensions of space one number of
energy three numbers for the momentum
because momentum is a vector
and that's only if you have a single
particle if you have a bunch of
particles or if you have a fluid or a
solid or the sun right the interior of
the sun there's also going to be
you know
pressure and there's going to be strain
and stress inside the object and it
turns out
all of these are related to each other
in relativity so you know again einstein
knew this he knew his physics very very
well
the right way to think about the
generalized version of mass that newton
would have used is something called the
energy momentum tensor in relativity and
it is a tensor with two indices that is
to say a four by four
array of numbers so what that means is
the energy momentum tensor has
components
they're since it's a four by four two
index tensor it has a
t t co component where t is for time it
has a t x component a t y component t z
component
and then you know an x t component x x x
y you know the whole bit those are the
four by four array of numbers and they
all have meanings the t t component of
the energy momentum tensor is the energy
density the amount of energy per cubic
centimeter
the spatial components the xx component
yy component the zz component that's the
pressure
inside the object and the what we call
the off-diagonal components the ones
that mix in t to x etc those are the
stress and strain and flow of heat
inside the object so it's all familiar
quantities from pre-relativity physics
but relativity bundles them together
into a nice compact form
a tensor with two indices good great
we're on the right track so if we want a
rule an equation for relativity
for gravity that generalizes newton's
equation on the right hand side of
newton's equation there's capital m or
m1 if you want the mass of the object
that is doing the pulling of the gravity
so on the right hand side of our
relativistic equation for gravity we
will put the energy momentum tensor
that's a good thing to put there
and on the left hand side what do we put
well we want the curvature right
we know what the curvature is it's the
riemann tensor
but there's a problem there's a problem
right out of the box
the energy momentum tensor has two
indices it's a four by four array okay
a little square matrix
the riemann tensor for the curvature has
four indices it is a four by four by
four by four array of numbers
you can't set them equal to each other
they're different geometric quantities
you can't even set them proportional to
each other just like you can't set a
tensor proportional to a vector
you need to set things proportional to
each other that are the same kind of
geometric object and the riemann tensor
sadly is just not a two index tensor
like the energy momentum tensor is
so what can you do are you stuck are you
you know is it a hopeless quest well no
there are ways that mathematicians have
worked out uh in this case professor
uh richie
actually uh professor ritchie's last
name was not richie richie is spelled
r-i-c-c-i
his real name was uh i forget his first
name but his last name was richie
carbostro richie dash carbastro that was
his last name it was the compound name
for some reason
when richie carbostro wrote his famous
article where he explains how to do this
he didn't put the second half of his
last name on the paper he just wrote it
as g richie rather than g richie
carbastro i don't know why but
from doing that the thing that he
invented is now called the ritchie
tensor
so basically there's a way to boil down
the riemann tensor whenever you have a
tensor that is many indices like the
riemann tensor has there are ways to
compress it to contract it into
something smaller
and for the riemann tensor in particular
there's a natural way to extract
from this four index tensor the riemann
tensor to extract it to index tensor
called the richie tensor r
mu nu
and now from the ritchie tensor now
we're on the right track in fact we can
go further you can go from the richie
tensor contracted again
to get a single scalar quantity which is
called the curvature scalar so you have
the four index tensor the riemann tensor
two index tensor the richie tensor zero
index tensor which is just a scalar
quantity called the curvature scalar
and since what we want to do is to set
some quantity characterizing the
curvature proportional to the energy
momentum tensor
the very obvious guess to make is that
the richie tensor is proportional to the
energy momentum tensor r mu nu
is proportional to t mu nu t mu nu being
the energy momentum tensor
and in fact this is so obvious that
einstein did it this is this was his
guess
turns out not to work so einstein
guessed this uh and he thought that
maybe he had it maybe he had the right
equation for general relativity for
gravity as a feature of the curvature of
space-time
it turns out not to work it turns out
that if that were the equation it would
violate energy conservation in a very
subtle way
and so einstein was racking his brains
about this and he eventually figured out
that what he needed to do was to combine
in a clever way the ritchie tensor or mu
nu
the curvature scalar r
and the metric tensor g mu nu
so that is why the right way to do it he
eventually figured out was to set r mu
nu minus one half r
g mu nu equals eight pi g
t mu nu that t mu nu is the energy
momentum tensor that capital g is
newton's constant of gravity eight and
pi are familiar numbers that you know
and the left-hand side army new minus
one-half r g mu nu
is a four by four matrix
a two index tensor that characterizes
part of the curvature of space-time part
of the riemann tensor you might ask what
about the other parts that we got rid of
that we sort of evaporated away when we
contrast contracted down the riemann
tensor to the richie tensor they're
still there and in fact those parts of
the riemann tensor describe the
propagation of gravitational waves so
gravitational waves don't need matter
and energy around to exist they can just
float through space-time all by
themselves so they are described by the
rich by the riemann tensor but the
einstein tensor is telling you how the
curvature of space-time responds to
matter and energy and so that is the
final wonderful answer so the
understanding that you have of rmu new
minus one half r d mu nu is that it is a
four by four array of numbers
constructed from another tensor the
metric tensor all by itself another four
by four array of numbers by taking
derivatives of it very carefully
cleverly and that metric tensor tells
you the distance along curves and the
correct way to take the derivatives
tells you the curvature and so this is
the curvature of space-time proportional
to the energy and momentum in space-time
small footnote there
we don't know
whether or not einstein actually got
einstein's equation first
we know that einstein came up with the
idea that gravity is the curvature of
space-time we know that he proposed
first that it was arm you knew
proportional to team you knew before he
eventually said arm you knew minus one
half are genuine proportional the team
you knew
but while he was struggling with that
last step
he was invited to visit the university
of guertigan by his friend the brilliant
mathematician david hilbert
and he said yes and einstein visits
gerdagan he gives a series of lectures
and at night over dinner he and hilbert
talk about general relativity because
again einstein i think was really super
duper smart but he also you know had
things he cared about and what he cared
about was physics he didn't care about
mathematics for the sake of mathematics
he learned just enough mathematics to
get by
hilbert was one of the world's great
mathematicians hilbert's space turns out
to be very important in quantum
mechanics for example
and hilbert listened to einstein talk
about you know this army knew blah blah
blah and he thought to himself he could
derive the right answer for the left
hand side in a very slick mathematically
high powered way
and so when einstein went back to berlin
hilbert stayed behind in gerd again and
hilbert
used what is called the principle of
least action to derive the correct
left-hand side of what we now know is
einstein's equation
and we don't know who got it first
because what we know is that einstein
said it in public first but there were
letters that went back and forth from
einstein to hilbert they were friends
and also there were papers that were
written but those papers were then
revised later on and we don't know if
the versions that we see are the first
versions or the last versions or
whatever so it's possible that hilbert
was the first person to get einstein's
equation right but that's okay
it still makes perfect sense to give
einstein the credit for it it was all
his ideas that went into it even if
hilbert did in fact do that last step
before einstein did okay so hopefully
this has given you
some
intuition for what it means when people
write down r mu nu minus one half r g
minou equals eight pi g t munu this is
an equation between four by four
matrices
the one on the left is derivatives of
the metric tensor which is a way of
characterizing the curvature of
space-time with a very definite formula
relating them the one on the right is
the amount of energy mass heat momentum
all that stuff also in space-time so
what do you do with it let's close the
story by giving you a little payoff for
being so patient listening to this what
do you do with this equation
well the way that i would say it is it's
a four-part process if you like but part
zero is think of a physical situation
you want to describe right like
the curvature of space-time around the
sun the thing that saturn moves in to
describe its orbit or the expansion of
the universe or a gravitational wave
passing by or two black holes spiraling
in whatever you want to specify okay
then given that step one is
you look for a general form of the
metric
so the metric is going to be a set of
four by four numbers right but they're
not really numbers
they're functions at every point in
space there's a different number the
metric depends on where you are in both
space and time okay
so you might guess
that the metric has a particular kind of
dependence like oh this component of the
metric depends on the x coordinate and
this one doesn't something like that or
you know if you look at the universe
which is uniform you're going to say
well in the x y and z directions the
metric is doing the same thing there's
no difference between x and y and z that
kind of thing is step one step two is
you use that
hypothesized form of the metric and you
calculate the riemann tensor and then
you boil it down and you calculate what
is called the einstein tensor i didn't
say that yet but this combination r mu
nu minus one half r d mu nu is called
the einstein tensor and you can
calculate it or you can have your
computer calculated you know there are
there are programs out there they
weren't around when i was doing this but
these days people rarely calculate the
einstein tensor anymore it's very sad
but you could calculate it or you could
have your computer calculated for you
then you ask okay for this physical
situation what should be the right-hand
side of einstein's equation what should
be the energy and momentum and stress
and all that stuff
and then finally you solve you set those
two things equal to each other
proportional to each other
the einstein tensor and the energy
momentum tensor and then you solve for
these functions that are still lurking
in your form of the metric
g x x is a function of y or whatever it
is that you're trying to solve for
and this is all very complicated
because the einstein
tensor is part of the riemann tensor the
riemann tensor is very very complicated
and einstein himself
thought it was basically an impossible
task
he thought that basically his equations
were so ugly
that you could approximate it so you
know he did approximate solutions for
light being deflected by the sun or
mercury being precessing because of
general relativity and all that stuff
but he thought an exact solution would
be too hard to get
uh but not everyone was so pessimistic
including one carl schwartshield
schwartshield was another german
physicist like einstein but unlike
einstein
this is all remember einstein put
forward general relativity in 1915 so
world war one is going on at the time
and short shield was actually serving in
the german army but because he was a
trained physicist and astronomer he
wasn't out there with a bayonet he was
calculating trajectories of missiles or
of uh artillery right of firing
artillery uh across the front
but they did you know occasionally give
even people working at the front uh some
shore leave as it were some vacation
time so
during his vacation short shield went
back to berlin and sat in on lectures by
einstein
on the general theory of relativity and
short shield was thinking like this is
awesome i love this stuff and so he goes
back to the front
and he sits down and tries to calculate
and try to solve einstein's equation for
a very simple problem namely
the gravitational field of the sun so he
said look let's idealize the sun is
perfectly spherical
and let's look at not what happens
inside the sun but what happens outside
so the great thing about outside the sun
is that there's nothing there there's no
energy or anything like that so rather
than
r mu nu minus one half r g minu equals
eight pi g t mu nu
t unio is zero in the absence in empty
space so you can just solve our mu nu
minus one half r d mu nu equals zero and
that's easier to do
and furthermore he said look i'm looking
at a situation where nothing is moving
i'm just trying to solve for what the
sun is doing not for what the planets
are doing at this point so there's no
dependence on time
and furthermore the only dependence on
space is spherically symmetric so the
metric whatever it's doing it will
depend on the distance from the sun
but it won't depend on the angle it
won't depend on the orientation where
you are it'll be completely spherically
symmetric so everything just depends on
r the distance from the sun to wherever
you are
and those guesses were enough to make
the problem tractable and simple enough
that he could solve it so he did
so he wrote down an exact solution to
einstein's equation called the
schwartshield metric and you can go look
it up uh i will even tell you what it is
so it's g mu nu what is what does it
look like when you say you have a
solution to einstein's equation you have
a metric
so that means you have a four by four
array of numbers that depend on where
you are in space and time the short
shield metric is static so it doesn't
depend on time at all
and it doesn't really depend on the
angle either so it only depends on r
and in fact as it turns out the only
components of the short shield metric
that physically matter
are the t t component remember because g
mu nu the mu and the new range over the
four coordinates in this case our four
coordinates because we're using
spherical coordinates our t
r theta phi rather than t x y z
the only components of the metric that
matter are g t t
and g r r
and they try to be reciprocals one over
inverses of each other g t t is one
minus two gm over r
where m is the mass of the object and r
is the distance
and g r r is minus one minus two g m
over r to the minus one power
why am i telling you this you're not
gonna remember this right you don't care
what the actual details are
i'll tell you why because it's actually
kind of amazing this is the payoff this
is what you get for sitting through all
this
the point is that you now have in your
hands a well
defined algorithm for
posing physical metrics and then
plugging them into einstein's equation
and solving them for what the actual
physical metric would be
that's what schwartshield did he sent it
to einstein einstein was very impressed
he agreed with it instantly
and they set about trying to understand
it and they realized that you know yes
it fit what we know about the sun and
the whole bit okay
but
let's think about the physical meaning
of what schwartshield did so
g
t t what is that that is the component
of the metric that's in the upper left
corner of this four by four matrix right
the very first thing that appears when
you write the metric as a little array
and the value is 1 minus 2 gm over r
where r is the distance to the object so
what is that doing
the the tt component of the metric tells
you
the relationship if you think about it
think about what minkowski said right
what is the metric telling you the time
elapsed along your clock
that's what you calculate using the
metric that's the distance that's the
space-time equivalent
of the distance in euclidean geometry is
the time elapsed along the clock
and that component of the metric is
telling you the relationship between the
time elapsed on your personal clock
and the time coordinate
t
right that's what gtt does the time
elapsed if you just move in time if you
don't move in space at all
the interval that you
denote on your clock that you measure
the space time interval the proper time
along your trajectory is just the square
root of gtt
times the time coordinate elapsed
so look at this function 1 minus 2 gm
over r
as r is big if you're very very far away
from the sun
you expect
that the gravitational field of the sun
is irrelevant right you're very very far
away from it and indeed when you're very
far away from the sun r is large
2g m over r
becomes close to zero because r is very
very large so 1 minus 2 gm over r is
approximately 1.
so what you're saying is if you're very
far away from the sun in the short
shield metric
the personal time that you measure on
your watch is one times the time
coordinate which is another way of
saying you're just measuring the time
coordinate as we usually do that's what
we think we're doing if we think as a
newtonian person would think we would
think there's a universal time that we
measure
fine that's good that's like a
consistency check a sanity check we're
on the right track
but
as r gets smaller and smaller you know
if you start out at large r
1 minus 2 gm over r is just
approximately 1 but then as you come
closer and closer
to r equals 0
you hit a point at r equals two g m
right
when r equals two g m so when the radius
the radial coordinate equals two times
newton's constant times the mass of the
sun
which by the way in the real world never
happens it never happens because the sun
itself
has a radius that is much bigger than
2gm
so
that's what people thought back in the
day short shield and einstein they knew
that and they're like ah who cares about
this weird thing that happens at r
equals 2 gm because it's inside the sun
where the solution doesn't apply the
solution only applies outside the sun
but we can imagine we can ask like what
if you squeezed the whole mass of the
sun down to a really really tiny object
smaller in radius than 2gm
what would happen
what happens is as you get closer and
closer to r equals 2gm that quantity 1
minus 2gm over r gets closer and closer
to zero
at r equals two g m it would be exactly
zero
and what that means is that if you go
hang out
near the radius r equals two gm
the time that elapses on your clock
is approximately zero
times the time coordinate in other words
you feel almost no time passing compared
to the people who stayed out far away
from the sun
so if you did that if you went back
close to r equal to gm
and then you hung out and then you came
back and you've been hanging out for a
couple days
the people you left behind have been
experiencing years or more of time
and that is time dilation that is
gravitational time dilation and what's
going on is that you've been hanging out
near the event horizon of a black hole
and this is the lesson this is the
payoff that
short shields solution to einstein's
equation implies the existence of
something called a black hole
nobody appreciated that at the time they
didn't appreciate it really until the
1950s or 60s they didn't know what was
really going on because they didn't
really understand how to ask questions
about the metric that weren't dependent
on the coordinate system they were using
this lesson about the coordinates being
human inventions hadn't quite sunken in
so they they didn't really know what to
say about the coordinates they thought
that time slowed down to zero at r
equals two gm and they didn't know what
to say beyond that
these days we know you can pick better
coordinates and you can go past r equals
two gm and you can go into the black
hole but the point is
there's very many interesting things to
say about black holes but my
philosophical point is a different one
the black holes were lurking there
inside einstein's equation as soon as he
wrote it down
this is the beauty of an equation this
is why we're going through all this
podcast why is it so important to
understand not just the words but also
the equations because einstein could
have said words like
gravity is the curvature of space-time
principle of equivalence blah blah blah
until he was blue in the face
it's only once you had that equation
that you could solve that equation and
ask what are the features of the
solution including features i might not
have anticipated even though i wrote
down the equation
in a very real sense the equation knows
more than you do
einstein's equation certainly knows a
lot more than einstein did about
solutions to einstein's equation and so
einstein never wanted black holes he
never even heard the term it was it was
coined i believe by john wheeler after
einstein passed away
he went to his grave not knowing that
his own theory predicted something
called black holes much less that they
would be crucially important in modern
astrophysics and we could see
their you know take pictures of their
vicinities and see the gravitational
waves they they made on all this stuff
that's why the equations are so
important as well as interesting because
if you take them seriously
they predict things that you yourself
would not have been able to predict
that's the beauty and the power
of expressing the laws of physics in
precise
and universal
quantitative terms that's why equations
are more than just intimidating
symbology they're a crucially important
way of thinking about how the world
works and it's also a testament to the
power of the laws of physics because
there are mathematical equations but the
fact that the laws of physics take the
form of such equations is amazing and
the fact that these equations can be
extended so far past the realm of our
experience when we invented them
einstein's equation also describes the
big bang or right after the big bang it
actually doesn't describe the big bang
itself the moment of t equals zero but
one minute after the big bang
einstein's equation makes a prediction
for how fast the universe should be
expanding and that prediction turns out
to be right on exactly right einstein
didn't even know there was such a thing
as the big bang much less that he was
trying to predict it so
that's why the equations are special
that's why i think it's worth doing a
little bit of effort which i do believe
that almost everyone can do successfully
to really appreciate what those
equations are trying to tell us in
general relativity and in physics more
generally there are more equations
than that to be found in this nice
little book that i wrote
the biggest ideas in the universe face
time in motion it's volume one there'll
be two more volumes coming up uh i hope
you all enjoy it and even if you don't i
hope you enjoyed this podcast bye bye
[Music]
you